what do you think makes women happy and
what makes men happy
what would you say
generally speaking all right let's see
what makes women happy i think what
makes women like do you mean like just
in terms of like fulfillment genuine
fulfillment or just like no genuine
fulfillment if women were going to track
a path to happiness what would that
include because i think it's very
different actually for men and women
like i would say for example
i think that women are happier when
there's uh more of a work-life balance
yeah i think that women are happier when
there's more peace in their life i think
women really thrive in moments of calm
and moments of peace we need that yes we
really really need yeah the only problem
is like when you have like when you i
think women get fulfillment from family
genuinely speaking and and and close
holidays personal connections and
relationships i think men get happiness
from family as well but also from
striving to be
especially financially better so just
trying to challenge themselves every
single day builds your character as a
man and that's kind of the hero's
journey that's what everybody fetishizes
about in every single movie the guy that
starts with nothing has to do everything
to get to where he wants to be so i
think that's what makes a man genuinely
feel fulfilled happiness and financial
success over time but that only comes
from having success in other things like
uh discipline and um and and and being
willing to and like do something every
single day
so i feel like men need to feel strong
and by strong i mean strong empowered
and for me and my observations i really
believe that women need to feel at peace
meaning that you're not worried about
about your guy and what he's doing
you're not you know worried about oh i
have to put in you know
hate to say it'll be controversial but
you know 18 hours a day at the office
how do you feel about women in the
workplace then because i believe that
when women have to compete directly
against men because men have
testosterone we have a complete event a
competitive advantage this is the first
time in human history women are
competing directly for resources against
men i think that adds a lot of stress
that women don't need so it's not for me
it's not only don't need but i think a
lot of them don't want right you know
but when you have that conversation with
most women do you think they're honest
about that no i don't i don't think
they're honest about it and i can say
this as somebody who you know i have had
the high power jobs which in media is
not easy you do a lot of free television
you're in buildings a lot you're you
spend a lot of time working
i
taught for years i don't know how much
you know about me but i taught middle
school and high school for years i
taught college and i was always a worker
i was always but i had limits i had
limits and i remember when i met my
husband who is very he's the kind of guy
that can go to an office and work for 16
hours and he's just laser focused and it
doesn't take a toll on him i remember
saying to him i could never do that it
would sap like my life force out of me
and i think that a lot of women
aren't happy and they're not happy doing
those things they want more work-life
balance they want more time for other
things they want to be able to sit
outside on the grounds with their kids
why is it why are we telling young women
that
careers are more important than family
then i think that that came from
women got very scared at some point and
i think this happened through feminism
where it became scary for them to rely
on men
i think that they worried about
things like being left and we're told
guys are gonna you know they'll spend
all their years building themselves up
and they'll grow these careers and then
if they leave you you'll have nothing i
think there's something that's making us
the women that leave like eighty percent
of the time is the worst that's not how
the messaging got to women though and i
think women felt very afraid of not
being self-reliant and that completes
the point that i was trying to make
about the propaganda and uh companies
influencing pop culture did you know
that the woman the lady who was the top
journalist for cosmopolitan i forget her
name y'all you people can look it up the
lady who's the top uh journalist for
cosmopolitan lied and when when the
magazine with that was at its highest
with his peak in terms of influence with
women she was lying about facts data and
statistics in order to
promote a more sex in the city lifestyle
because it would sell more magazines all
those women were miserable exactly on
sex in the city though anybody who
watched that show and it's interesting
because they came out with reboot i
don't mean to interrupt you they came
out with a reboot and everybody realized
how sad like if you
i grew up with that show yeah so i
watched it young and i was like oh it's
fun it's a bunch of 30-somethings
running around in the city i didn't
absorb it i watched it now i'm a
grown-ass woman i have a kid i have a
family and i looked and i said oh want a
bunch of scents
and that's why there's so much societal
pressure on women because when you're at
the top of the world you're 18 nobody
can tell you nothing you every woman is
going to agree with you and every man is
going to agree with you because they
want to sleep with you so everything
you're told is that you're right you're
perfect you're beautiful there used to
be societal pressure to tell women hey
you might want to get pregnant before
you're 30 because when you turn 30 90 of
your eggs are going by the time you turn
40 97 of all your eggs are going when
you hit 35 you were in high risk
pregnancy that was what we knew
historically speaking so we had social
pressures in order to push women to do
those things and to rush to do those
things even if they didn't feel like it
because life isn't about doing what you
want to do all the time sometimes it's
about doing what you have to do doing
what's more responsible so it also is
different um pbd and i had a
conversation the other day patrick um
said to me are you gonna have more kids
and i said no i said just one for me um
i said you know and it would be hard to
do all of this you know with a child and
he made a comment about i said i don't
remember how the conversation went after
that but i said something to him like
you know it's it's hard to be a ceo it
would be really hard to be a ceo for you
if you had morning sickness and there's
just differences that come along and
those are not burdens i mean the i'm i'm
a super superhero i gave birth to a
child i mean that is my biggest
superpower that's insane i i just
discredit that too much
i always say that women are literally
the the creators of culture like i tell
like when guys go if you're married
that's almost that's like having being a
prostitute or like being that's
prostitution because she's technically
only there for your resources that's not
what it is women contribute a lot women
are the
social centers of america they organize
social communal events they create
culture amongst kids the man imprints
his values on the woman since she spends
a lot of time with the kids she imprints
the values on the kids and now we're in
a situation where women are told to work
the kids are undermined they're being
pinned all this lgbtq stuff because
women have decided to work the kids are
more obese than ever because when they
come home they eat fast food and
nobody's happy that's right
all of that again i think comes from the
root cause people always ask me that one
question i always get in interviews is
what's your biggest accomplishment and
i'm like i created a person
i built a human from start to finish and
that is my biggest i forget don't talk
to me about the view or fox news or i
made a human being yeah because when
when it's all said and done when you're
80 when you're 80 years old sitting in
your deathbed that's right no one's
gonna care you're not gonna be thinking
i wish i did more work you're gonna be
thinking i spent more time with the
people i love and you're gonna be
surrounded by generations of people like
like
unfortunately we just had a loss in the
family or one of my on my right side
yeah and but when we were there
i i looked i looked at my wife and i
told her just imagine how beautiful this
is she has generations of people around
her that came from her specifically and
i just i think that's a beautiful thing
and i think that we don't talk about how
important that role is enough and the
and i think it's predominantly women
that downplay that role i don't know a
single man that has said i don't
that has made fun of a woman for cooking
and cleaning and taking care of her
family i don't know a single man that's
ever
downplayed a woman other than an 18 year
old in a call of duty lobby or something
i don't know a single man that does that
so those pressures to be working women
and to be more stressed out is coming
from other women because they have
propaganda in their brains about
feminism and it's just to make money if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here